y hablar sobre corrupción por más de que
pueda parecer que es un tema
obvio o evidente es tan extenso ha
empezado hace tanto y es tan grande que
uno simplemente no sabe por dónde
empezar por más de que tú pienses que es
un tema sencillo no sabes por dónde
empezar
entonces eso estuve pensando en todo el
tiempo que me dieron para preparar esta
presentación
como podría hablar de corrupción que
podría decirles a ustedes de corrupción
qué mensaje podría darles para que
ustedes lo consideren lo piensen lo
analicen
podría hablar tal vez sobre qué es
corrupción
pero eso creo que ya todos lo sabemos
corrupciones
un alcalde que le roba dinero a su
municipalidad un policía que recibe una
coima un juez que recibe un soborno para
favorecer a una de las partes corrupción
es un presidente que le dice a un
contratista ya mira compadre construyes
un puente pones que cada ladrillo costó
100 dólares vamos a medias y me traes la
plata en un maletín a mi casa y por
supuesto cuando revienta el chongo esta
persona termina pero fue en eeuu
una historia un poco familiar no
de que podríamos hablar cuando hablamos
de corrupción de la historia tal vez hay
un libro que se titula historia de la
corrupción en el perú escrito por el
foso kilos 2013 en este libro los siete
episodios o capítulos muchos netflix
disculpen los siete capítulos de este
libro que van desde la colonia hasta el
segundo gobierno alan garcía básicamente
nos dice que la misma estructura la
misma historia se ha repetido se ha ido
repitiendo una y otra y otra vez un
grupo de poder que se aprovecha de la
posición que tiene versus un grupo que
intenta hacer un cambio
una reforma tal vez bueno ya la moda
historia
terminamos con la charla entonces de que
podemos hablar cuando hablamos de
corrupción podríamos hablar tal vez de
cifras
alguien sabe que representa esta cifra
que aparece en pantalla
honestamente está apareciendo mucho en
esta campaña podría levantar la mano
aquella persona que sabe que represente
este número
pero nadie no lo creo
uno no se está rascando
estos doce mil seiscientos millones de
soles no es el pozo de la tinta
es lo que le cuesta la corrupción al
perú esto es una cifra que proviene de
un informe de defensoría del pueblo en
el año 2017 eso quiere decir para
entenderlo un poco mejor
perdón
que en el 2016 en 32 mil 925 casos
se chorearon 12 mil 600 millones de
soles
ahora estos son los casos que están
documentados
hay muchos que todavía no están
documentados y hay muchos que nunca van
a estar documentados por supuesto en
este informe también aparecen las
ciudades con la mayor cantidad de casos
no lima esta primera aunque segunda
junín tercera
para que tengas una idea de la magnitud
de estas cifras porque al principio la
victoria bueno 12.600 no es tanto bueno
si es tanto con esa plata puede comprar
una persona 14.607 ferraris de lujo 545
menciones de rihanna
puede contratar por 110 años a cristiano
ronaldo con el sueldo actual de 30
millones
y esto sí me dio muy me dolió mucho en
el corazón 7 millones 411 mil 764
playstation 4
sin juegos y con un mando
y que podríamos hablar cuando hablamos
de corrupción esa fue la pregunta que
estuvo en mi mente en los últimos días
tratando de encontrar la mejor forma
bueno podríamos hablar de cifras
podríamos hablar de historias podríamos
hablar de casos si les pregunto o les
pido que piensen en un caso
inmediatamente van a pensar en uno y si
le digo que piensen en nombres va a ser
peor y de inmediato estoy seguro me han
dicho que no diga ninguno así que no voy
a decir ninguno
cuando estuve pensando en la mejor forma
de desarrollar esto
me di cuenta de que esta misma pregunta
ya me la había hecho hace cuatro años
tengo cuatro años haciéndome la misma
pregunta cómo hablar sobre corrupción
y les voy a contar por qué
en las elecciones municipales del 2014
cuando postulaban
el señor luis castañeda susana villarán
enrique cornejo etcétera etcétera me
acuerdo mucho que la gente hablaba
buenas de candidatos de propuestas
hablaban de las encuestas y sobre todo
de la persona que ocupaba el primer
lugar en ellas era alcalde luis
castañeda que tenía un porcentaje que
truepic duplicaba duro duplicaba
triplicaba al segundo lugar
pero también había algo de lo que
hablaba mucho hace cuatro años de algo
llamado caso comunicore
levanten la mano honestamente por favor
honestamente
quién sabe qué es el caso comunicore
una persona 23 bien bien
si hubieran hecho esa pregunta hace
cuatro años yo tampoco hubiera levantado
la mano no tenía ni idea es más hasta el
prince que estaba metida otra gente que
no tiene nada que ver
y lo peor no era
solo que no sabía de qué se trataba sino
que cuando lo intentaba cuando decía
bueno todo el mundo le comunicó entonces
voy a intentar nuclear qué cosas
comunicore me va peor porque todas las
noticias que encontraba
sufrían de tres problemas al menos para
mí esto es totalmente subjetivo me daba
cuenta que las noticias que hablaban
sobre el tema eran incompletas me decían
por ejemplo tal personaje está
involucrado en el caso tal ok perfecto
pero quién es ese personaje
recién escuché ese nombre o me mostraban
documentos que yo no entendía por ningún
lado porque lo revisaba y simplemente no
podía entender nada noticias que también
hablaban en un lenguaje difícil y hasta
creo que se esforzaban por hacerlo
difícil y noticias que eran aburridas la
verdad porque yo intentaba siquiera
saber qué significaba la sola palabra
comunicore y me costó como un mes
entenderlo
así estuve durante mucho tiempo en la
campaña pasada hace cuatro años a
diferencia de esta campaña que ha
empezado hace diez días
en el 2014 empezó como tres meses de
anticipación así que tuve buen tiempo
para averiguar
cuando intenté averiguar
me puse un poco terco con el tema porque
de verdad quería saber por qué todo el
mundo hablaba de esto una revista que
había en mis manos
una revista que cambió mi vida es un
poco difícil no sé qué en qué otro
contexto podría una persona utilizar esa
frase una persona una revista cambió mi
vida pero en este caso fue verdad cuando
leí la revista poder que publicó la
investigación de daniel yovera uno los
mejores periodistas de investigación de
este país por fin pude saber que era
comunicore claro leyendo 12 páginas en
letra tamaño 9
pero pude entender que coser a
comunicore
por fin gracias a esta publicación supe
que esas 12 páginas y esas 50 webs y
esos y esas 50 entrevistas que había
revisado me contaban algo muy sencillo
en realidad que había una empresa que se
llamaba relima que la municipalidad de
lima le debía un poco más de 30 millones
de soles y habían acordado en pagarlos
en 10 años
la empresa estaba molesta obviamente a
quien quien va a aceptar que le paguen
en 10 años pero de un momento a otro
apareció una en una empresa que se
llamaba comunicore y le dijo a ella mira
yo te compro tu deuda pero estoy en la
mitad haya bueno solo esperar diez años
importa y le da la plata pero se voltea
y le dice la municipalidad o la tengo
para comprarte toda la deuda
y así se desaparecen 21 millones de
soles
si hicieron como
como comunicore más allá de lo que pueda
significar las siglas significa la
pérdida de 21 millones de soles
en lima en nuestra capital
cuando supe fui consciente de lo que
había sucedido cuando me enteré digamos
cuando me spoiler yo mismo la historia
me indigna y dije acá tengo que hacer
algo
no algo al menos hacer algo más que
entrar a twitter y poner castañeda roba
pero hace obra y ponerle me enoja todas
todas las noticias tiene que ser algo
más sentí que tenía que hacer algo más
así que dije bueno todas las noticias
que estamos revisando tienen estas
fallas están incompletas hablan en
difícil y son aburridas entonces voy a
hacer lo contrario en lugar de escribir
un texto de 50.000 caracteres
voy a hacer un vídeo
si voy a hacer un vídeo puedo hacerlo no
tengo cámara pero tengo amigo que tiene
cámaras suficiente nos editar pero él
sabe editar
genial no sé nada de audio pero tengo un
amigo que toca guitarra así que tiene
que saber algo de audio así que el 16 de
septiembre del 2014 una fecha que
también es muy importante al menos en mi
historia
nace
un canal de youtube que se llama el
diario de curva
cuya función bueno cuando nació en
verdad hay unos cuantos kilos menos
la función era muy sencilla hacer o
facilitarle el trabajo a todo aquel a
toda aquella persona que quiere
enterarse de lo que está sucediendo pero
de una forma completa que no tenga que
buscar más por otros lugares de una
forma fácil hablando de forma sencilla y
de una forma entretenida por supuesto
que no sean bloques de texto con sin
ningún tipo de imagen
cuándo
hago este vídeo por supuesto recibo que
yo pensaba que iba a tener pues como 100
visitas y para mis 100 visitas eran no
sé pues todo un edificio un grabado no
calculé el impacto que iba a tener por
supuesto cuando llegué a mi casa
ministro lars siempre cuento esta
anécdota en algunas entrevistas que yo
no tenía plan de datos en el celular así
que me iba a trabajar y mi celular
prácticamente estaba muerto todo el día
y cuando regrese a mi casa comenzó a dar
vueltas solito
por todas las vibraciones de
notificaciones que me van a matar en
cualquier momento me mandan la moto y ya
fui
pero desde hace 4 años
me dedico a hacer esto a contar casos de
corrupción a contar historias a contar
lo que sucede en nuestra ciudad a lo que
sucede en lo que sucede en nuestro país
casi 200 vídeos
10 millones de visitas y 100 soles de
ganancias
he podido cumplir creo yo con una labor
necesaria para nuestra ciudad y nuestro
país
y es que la corrupción en nuestro país
es
increíble digna de series películas
documentales todo lo que sea netflix
absolutamente todos son unos casos
increíbles que mucha gente si se los
cuentas no van a saber diferenciar si
precisamente estamos hablando de algo
que sucedió o de alguna temporada de
alguna serie se lo juro por ejemplo
en una noche de abril del 2015 una
camioneta super ficha de más de 200 mil
dólares que hasta ahora no sé ni cómo se
pronuncia la marca una camioneta súper
cara y vapor sanmiguel y de pronto es
atacada
recibe 24 impactos de bala y dos
granadas por supuesto cuando la policía
comienza a investigar sobre quién era el
dueño de este vehículo descubre que esta
persona esté la azúcar +11 tenía
muchísimos otros vehículos más lujosos
vivía en un palacio y estaba involucrado
en uno de los casos que terminó siendo
una de las redes más grandes de
narcotráfico de nuestro país
saben de qué acaso soy hablando no
grande capo grande como
tony montana recuerda en esos audios
verdad yo no tenía el rin tong a bordo
este caso es tan increíble que a pesar
de haber sucedido hace tantos años
continua hasta el día de hoy hasta este
momento este caso continúa porque me
imagino que ustedes han escuchado los
audios de la corrupción el caso cuellos
blancos verdad ustedes sabían que ese
caso empieza precisamente aquí
qué tiene que ustedes me imagino se
hacen estar preguntando que tienen que
haber jueces y fiscales con tony montana
lo que pasó fue que las autoridades
comenzaron a investigar
a todas estas bandas de narcotráfico y
comenzaron a chuponear sus teléfonos y
resulta que algunos de estos narcos
hablaban con jueces y fiscales es por
ello que nace el caso que estamos viendo
actualmente y hay peores
tan listo por uno más
super ánimos es así
en el año 2013
la policía de brasil investiga a unos
tipos que sabían que estaban lavando
dinero ya los tenían fichados hace
tiempo los comienzan a investigar los
comienzan a seguir y cuando realizan la
detención arrestan a un pata que se
llama alberto yusef le suena ese nombre
alberto yusef era un tipo al que tenían
en la mira hace tiempo sabía que lavaba
dinero así que cuando lo investigan aún
más descubren un movimiento curioso en
sus cuentas bancarias le había regalado
un carro una camioneta a otro tipo
también conocido llamado roberto dacosta
que era funcionario de petrobras una de
las si no es la más grande petrolera de
brasil por supuesto que cuando los
atrapan y comienzan a interrogarlos les
dijeron ok o hablas o no te va a sacar
nada
hablaron los dos por supuesto no y
cuando comienzan a contar todas las
cosas en las que estaban metidas la
policía al principio no lo creyó porque
parecía una historia sacada esta vez de
mario puzzo era increíble ellos decían
que pertenecían a una red no solamente
de funcionarios públicos sino de
presidentes y presidentes de otros
países y dueños de constructoras tan
multimillonarias cuyos dueños si les
daba la gana decía hoy día me compré un
planeta ya me compro saturno de la
cantidad de plata que tenía increíble ya
saben de que acaso esté hablando ahora
caso de brecht marcelo odebrecht el
hombre que
el dueño de la empresa que confesó
solamente en el 2016 si no me equivoco
que entregaron más de 700 millones de
dólares en coimas y aportes de campaña
en más de 11 países alrededor del mundo
qué tal
esta es la corrupción de nuestro país
así de increíble así de cinematográfica
así de triste
cuando hablamos de corrupción por
supuesto la pregunta cae por sí sola
como luchar contra la corrupción que
podemos hacer nosotros para luchar en
contra de nosotros ciudadanos por
supuesto
nosotros no somos jueces ni fiscales así
que no podemos investigar
en teoría no sé si lo sepan los
ciudadanos podemos llevar iniciativas
legislativas al congreso podríamos
llevar proyectos de ley pero no llevarle
un proyecto ley a este congreso
y me cuentas qué tal te va me cuenta si
te dejaron entrar siquiera vamos a ver
cómo les va
luchar contra la corrupción aunque no lo
crean en nuestro papel de ciudadanos va
por algo muy sencillo y es estar
informados
cuando tú te informas de lo que está
sucediendo cuando eres consciente de la
noticia algo va a pasar en ti va a ver
un cambio
no vas a tener la misma actitud que
tenías antes vas a ser diferente te vas
a comer el pleito vas a romper la única
regla de tu casa que puso tu mamá que
dice que no se habla de religión y
política no la rompes y demás logras el
almuerzo a la mamá en el día de la madre
y hablas sobre las elecciones y le
valoran la cena navideña la abuela para
hablar de alan garcía
no interesa porque estás informado y
sabes lo que está pasando eres
consciente entras a una especie de nivel
de conocimiento que te impide mantenerte
al margen porque hay mucha gente incluso
músicos últimamente
no voy a mencionar su nombre
que dice que la mejor forma es ser
apolítico no meterse hacerse el loco
votar en blanco o dibujar ya saben qué
les tengo una mala noticia para eso
otra en blanco no soluciona nada
no votar o dibujar ciertas cosas no
solucionan nada en absoluto y no
solamente no soluciona algo sino que lo
empeora porque le estás ayudando aunque
no lo creas a los candidatos que van en
el primer lugar sabían eso verdad no
votar mantener su voto blanco en blanco
perdón reducen el porcentaje y lo
favorecen
antes de terminar esta presentación
quisiera compartirles una frase que
causó mucho impacto en mí
dice todo se mueve con plata y abogados
mafiosos
levanten la mano las personas que
piensan que yo me inventado esa frase
nadie muy bien
la confianza en mí
usted es de cuando creen que proviene
esa frase del primer gobierno de alan
garcía
alberto fujimori
alejandro toledo ollanta humala
belaunde tal vez no sé cuando creen que
proviene esta frase 10 años
francisco pizarro
les tengo otra mala noticia
quería hace dos meses
estas frases de hace dos meses y la dice
el expresidente de la corte suprema del
callado walter ríos en una conversación
con uno de sus amigos unas
conversaciones que se aseguró que muchos
hemos disfrutado
le dice hoy cómo vamos a hacer para
solucionar este problema no seas
todo se mueve con plata y abogados
mafiosos
esto no solamente lo está diciendo una
persona que se supone que está a cargo
de la justicia en el callado es el
presidente
de la corte suprema es un tipo que
debería
ser un ejemplo
esto es lo que nosotros tenemos que
evitar esto es lo que tiene que parar y
depende mucho de nosotros nos haremos
congresistas no seremos jueces no
tendremos el poder de fiscalización pero
con nuestro voto
elegimos a un congreso y deberíamos
elegir a un congreso que no proteja a
este tipo de personajes que no los
blinde que no sean sus cómplices
con nuestro voto faltan muy pocos días
para las elecciones
piensen muy bien a quién le van a dar su
voto piensen muy bien si quieren
desaprovechar la oportunidad de generar
un cambio porque eso está en nuestras
manos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]